everybody's square with the rules
everybody ready to go
okay i i see a knowing nod from both
captains lebron you're first
you're up who you got
uh with my first pick in the 2021
all-star game team lebron selects
giannis and cupo greek freak
charles and kenny were also on board
with that
k.d the first pick has been made who you
got
with the second pick the 2021
maybe the all-star draft i'm going to
select kyrie irving
brooklyn team eight goes to kevin durant
this uh this is kind of playing out the
way i thought it might play out lebron
if
especially if you take the guy that i'm
thinking you're gonna take right now
you're up
with my second pick uh team lebron
selects
chef curry from the golden state
warriors
why did you know it was going to stay
out like that how did you know
i i wasn't i'm sure all right i thought
he was going to take luca
oh man if i had a chance to take giannis
and and steph
i don't know with my first two picks i
think i would go in that direction
yeah how are you gonna how are you gonna
go wrong when you're drafting from this
field you're not so go ahead kevin
for me
um well my second pick i'm gonna go joe
ellenbee
nice that's yeah that's about right
there you gotta balance it out
since he's not playing he's gotta give
kyrie somebody that he can throw that
ball inside too okay i like that all
right lebron
with my forehead with my third pick um
i'm gonna go with luca magic
from the dallas mavericks you still got
them brian man i got them to team lebron
but you got them to team lebron
okay
inside jokes are not allowed right here
you got
four you got four names four names up
there among the starters uh
kevin durant what you're thinking
all right my third pick i'm gonna go
with the 2020
all-star game mvp kawhi leonard
yes he did win it in chicago a year ago
lebron
you have your pick of those three and
then the next two will automatically go
to kevin and with my last pick to round
up my starting five
i'm going to go with the card you cannot
use in blu-ray or guts
[Laughter]
nine triple doubles for the joker is he
is the uh
the final pick of lebron joker
among the starters so that means that
that's the big joke
so that means kevin durant gets uh the
league's leading scorer in bradley beal
who has 21 games of
30 or more and jason tatum who has
uh was because of his ranking in the
voting and the
and the balloting uh was moved into the
starting field so
the starting lineups are set for the
all-star game 20-21